hey this is presto Walker The Daily
Mail's headline reads turkey Matt's
problem sweeping social media leaves
many scratching their heads the sons
headline is this bind boggling Matt's
problem is stumping social media the
problem comes from mathematician Ed
Southall from the University of
Huddersfield and the Twitter handle at
solve my maths so what is this problem
start out with the square from the
bottom corner of the square draw a line
to the opposite midpoint then connect
the other two corners of the square
consider the triangle form between these
two lines and the square side what
fraction of the square is shaded can you
figure it out give this problem a try
and when you're ready keep watching the
video for a solution
so here's one way that you can solve it
there are many other ways you can solve
it you can share your method in the
comments or you can make a video send me
a link and I will share a link to your
video so here's one way that you can
solve the problem first let's scale this
blue triangle by 50% next rotate the
green triangle by a hundred and eighty
degrees then move the small triangle so
what this shows is that the green and
blue triangles are similar and the green
triangle is scaled by 50% let's prove
this notice that vertical angles are
equal and then alternate angles are
equal because the two sides of the
square are parallel to each other
furthermore the green triangle side is
50% of the square side and the blue
triangles base is a square side
therefore we get the scaling factor of
50% consequently the green triangles
height is 50% of the blue triangles
height so if this height is H the blue
triangles height has to be twice as big
which is to H this means the squares
side length is equal to 3 H so now we
can solve for the area of the blue
triangle and the area of the square in
terms of H the blue triangles area is
1/2 times its height times its base so
we have 2 H times 3 H all over 2 and
this will equal 3 H squared the squares
area is equal to its side length 3 H
squared this works out to be 9 H squared
and now the fraction of the square
that's shaded is the blue triangles area
to the entire squares area so this will
be the quantity 3 H squared all over 9 H
squared and that simplifies to be 1/3
did you figure it out
thanks for watching this video please
subscribe to my channel I make videos on
math you can catch me on my blog mind
your decisions if you like this video
you can check out my books which are
listed in the video description and you
can support me on patreon if you have a
math topic you can email me presh at
mind your decisions calm and you can
catch me on social media either at mind
your decisions or a pressure Locker